with this from clown world and uh this
is uh this is nothing unique it's just
another one of these videos where we
have far- leftists tearing down posters
for the people who are kidnapped and
being held hostage yeah there's a bunch
of these videos there's another video
where a guy puts up a flyer for a Thai
farmer not even an Israeli uh uh citizen
a guy who is just working in in Israel
who was kidnapped and this Asian woman
basically in front of him tears down his
flyer his property destroys it and then
basically tells them to screw off I see
these people and what they're doing this
is evil MH this is this is this is
malicious intentional evil these people
think they're justified in causing harm
chaos and destruction and so this is the
challenge I see when it comes to I don't
I don't I I don't care to get in the
history of the region we just talk about
literally October 7th you have people
Glide in kill a bunch of civilians Max
Blumenthal said it's because they see
civilians as targets of opportunity said
I'm sorry specifically the music
festival was a target of opportunity and
they target civilians to use his
bargaining chips against the Israeli
government I'm like oh okay so they're
evil that's it right evil and uh what's
that you say the US has done really
horrible things in the Middle East hey I
never said we were the good guys I'm
saying right now we've got a crisis and
what happens is you see these people in
New yor York City defending Hamas
cheering on Hamas celebrating it they're
now in the United States they're in the
west there was this massive protest in
London this is why I don't believe
anything they say I I understand what
you're saying and let's talk about that
story and what's going on there what is
that being done what's being done here
with this uh imagery this is Despicable
what these people are doing okay but why
has this become news uh this has become
news because it it serves as a
deflection it serves as a deflection it
says instead of being angry about what's
going on in in uh the Gaza Strip what's
happening to people dying instead we're
to we're we're diverted into this uh
this particular U you know uh despicable
act that takes the pressure off of
Israel in effect this works to this
works as propaganda but you know you but
sure but you know why this imagery is
important why why you see these I think
it's very important but what are they
doing with it that's the question these
people these people given the chance
would kill you in your sleep I don't
know that I mean listen I'm not sure
what does decolonize mean it means to
get rid of the
colonizers how do you do that well I
mean let's talk about what from from The
River To The Sea means well I agree with
that that's nonsense rhetoric and I
certainly would never uh use this is I'm
not saying you do I'm saying these
people have an extremist ideology it is
widespread in the west now and that's
the point I was making about Israel the
The Clash of warfare with and Western
sensibilities we as Western liberal
nations are like we do not want to like
wipe out an entire people we want to
figure out how to stop the fighting and
then chill everybody the F out their
ideology is from The River To The Sea
yeah if if you even just walk through
what that means it's it's horrendous
they're talking about genocide but I
mean they're not they're not capable of
executing it okay so so the issue then
becomes Western sensibilities would say
act in such a way that allows them to
persist the people who would kill you in
your sleep that's a liberal Paradox but
it's yeah exactly exactly that's that's
that's that's the The Clash of Western
sensibilities with modern warfare if it
were inversed and the Israelis were were
in the Gaza Strip there is no question
they would be shoved into the ocean and
mass executed by by the Palestinians
that's that's the golden my a uh point
but I I mean look I don't I don't know
about that I I guess we're going to have
to judicate the in a little bit it's I'm
not I'm not here to to talk about the
the the history of the region let's just
we'll remove Israel palestin from this
if far leftists like this are given
power we see what they do with it they
kill people well they do more than that
they they they kill and torture yeah
they try to uh they try they're
totalitarians at base okay leftists are
total it's in it's intrinsic to leftist
ideology uh this is what they did in the
Soviet Union I mean once they gained
power leftists are totalitarian okay
they're for free speech they're for all
this when they're aspirant but once they
gain power they become like uh you know
Lon and and Stalin and even then it's
not even necessarily that they're free
speech the Liberals are for free speech
I don't know if I would even I don't
know if there are any liberals where
where are the Liberals well we're here I
guess yes I guess classical liberal but
um my point is this to to sort of move
on from the the the the broad topical
Israel Palestine but more into the
philosophical and ideological we are we
are confronted by right now um actually
we we can maybe pull this up in a little
bit Elon Musk saying the woke M virus is
destroying civilization you take a look
at San Francisco we'll go into he was on
Jan podcast but you take a look at what
the woke left represents and what do you
see 16-year-olds chanting from The River
To The Sea MH they don't know they don't
care but they will do it well this this
isn't just you know look I I admit and
that's why I'm involved in this and this
is why I was asked to be a candidate
because I am I have been involved in
cultural uh issues and this is a
cultural War we we must fight in the
battle of ideas and so my my bigger
question is how do you win against a
group of people who you know want you
dead when you as a faction try to
preserve life right they have to they
have to be deprogrammed uh frankly they
have to be deprogrammed that's not easy
almost imposs almost impossible in this
day and age in the age of the internet
when you cannot get them away from a
phone when you cannot actually get them
out of the environment that's used it's
not just the colleges it's not just the
schools it's not just the elementary
schools it's the it's everything they're
getting on their phone I don't think
there's a liberal solution because in
order to pull someone from like to to
get someone to leave a cult you have to
remove them from the cult remove I got
to say it happened to me Tim I I
mentioned at the beginning of the show I
used to be a Marxist you know what did
it for me I was traumatized by them and
that caused my eyes to open once I was
traumatized by the left I then said this
this is a totalitarian uh contenent that
I want nothing further to do with at all
and I instantly became a civil
libertarian this can happen they eat you
know the left eats its own but not not
quite fast enough I think that the the
attack the terror attack on the 7th did
a lot to wake a lot of Jewish liberals
up or or what a lot of liberals in
general liberals in general I've had
several people who definitely like who
were very um very much BLM in 2020 who
started to at least I I don't know if
they were just getting their news from
different sources but saw the stuff that
Patrice Culler said back in 2015 who are
now seeing that what you were sold in
those in in those early years in 2020
which everyone told you said this is not
what it is it's look at what their
website says look at what all this
information say they weren't willing to
listen they weren't they were too filled
with emotion at that time and because it
was scary the the consequences of saying
I am not for black lives matter you know
in 2020 if you were not a staunch
conservative that had people around you
that would support that and that also
agreed with you right you were not going
to go out this is true this happened
with Co of course as well these people
effectively become State agents uh these
people that are walking around telling
get the mask on and they're actually
corralling you into the state's
propaganda and its
narrative no go ahead they have uh these
programs where this is like 10 15 years
ago you a company would ask you to go
out and write down license plate numbers
and where you saw them so that the state
and private companies could track down
the people and know where they were Mass
surveillance essentially snitch on your
neighbors but here's the scary thing
they don't need it anymore nope because
now you're you're carrying around a
tracking device everywhere you go yeah
you are so the the the the uh the main
issue I see with this is okay these
videos of them tearing down the poster I
think are extremely important the
reaction from the from the left cheering
on even right now these Mass protests in
New York uh and I say cheering on Hamas
I quite literally mean it I am not being
cute and conflating paltin with Hamas
they're in New York bull horning in
support of Hamas calling them the
resistance fighters who fired x amount
of rockets and killed x amount of
settlers they say settlers are not
civilians how do you I mean is it is it
this is the
challenge how do you deprogram someone
when you cannot isolate them from the
information the challenge we face as
people who believe in you know civil
libertarian values the right of free
speech is that okay on a platform like X
or on Facebook or YouTube we're going to
let everybody speak what happens silos
emerge of far-left extremism we allow
that to happen then within that sphere
they start spreading oppressing and
crushing their opponents gaining more
and more power and silencing the rest of
us if we allow them the platform use it
to destroy us they will not allow us the
platform so we we we have set ourselves
up at a at a in in a downward slope as
it were where where it seems and this is
why again Elon Musk we'll pull that up
in a second why he bought Twitter to
reverse this process but how do you de
like the the answer to deprogramming
these people ban Tik Tok there you go
ban Tik Tok regulate the algorithms and
mandate well you might look at the fact
that exactly you can't am I supposed to
expect that the US government is going
to be I don't want the US government
doing that either so the problem is what
would need to happen is an organic
pro-american you know o OG ideological
faction cancelling people and saying
this is the way we do things and if you
are a communist or a fascist we don't we
don't sell to you we don't welcome you
and our stores well it's called yeah I
mean this this is very much of a a
tradition within libertarianism it's
kind of a you know uh physical removal
of Communists from our midst uh but
let's get back to the technology aspect
if we can the problem is not just that
these people are cultivated on the in
these Echo chambers that until musk
bought Twitter and I think musk is kind
of a Black Swan right now until he
bought Twitter the whole uh big digital
social media and search was all
dominated by leftism all the way down
the line big uh Google for example is
Googling your phone yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net